bonjour nous sommes le 3 janvier
bienvenue sur tv fil 78 pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 lecture le
journal de la rédaction voici
quelques-uns des sujets que nous allons
développer au cours de la prochaine demi
heure des cours de langue de signes à
elancourt c'est pour bientôt pour qui et
comment se déroulent les leçons et pense
en plateau avec notre invité
représentants de l'organisme de
formation qui intervient sur cette ville
la mairie de montigny le bretonneux
propose un service de recyclage de
sapins de noël et pendant ce temps elle
les cadeaux du père noël trouve aussi
une seconde vie ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à revendre leur présent les
événements marquants de 2013 ce qui a
fait l'actualité donc département entre
janvier et juin ce sera enfin d'édition
il existait déjà l encours des cours de
langue des signes depuis plusieurs
années mais le dispositif va être
renforcée en cette année 2014 je reçois
à présent jean yves plumaçon jour dont
bienvenue en plateau de la société
wizard interact directeur des opérations
pour cette société qui intervient lors
des leçons dispensées sur la ville on va
peut-être déjà rappelé le dispositif que
vous avez mis en place c'est depuis 2009
que vous intervenez sur cette commune
oui depuis 2009 nous avons des contacts
permanents avec la mairie et nous avons
commencé par des coups on va dire
classique de langue des signes française
alors pour 2014 vous voulez mettre en
place un nouveau dispositif intensif
c'est à dire alors intensifs et accéléré
surtout le accéléré important parce que
nous avons changé la méthode nous avons
mis en place des cursus qui permettent
donc d'apprendre une méthode qui nous
permet la panda l'un des signes de façon
plus rapide environ quatre fois plus
vite quelles sont les astuces pour
apprendre quatre fois plus vite que
quatre fois plus vite une longue alors
bien sûr là l'astuce c'est quoi et et
l'astuce et que nous nous arrêtons pas
en fait uniquement sous le vocabulaire
mais plutôt nous utilisons des
techniques de mémorisation et des
techniques d'apprentissage rapide en
fait vous travaillez comme pour une
langue étrangère c'est exactement ça la
méthode est basée sur l apprendre des
techniques des langues étrangères que
nous avons adapté la langue des signes
ça marche c'est possible d'apprendre
aussi vite vous avez déjà testé un petit
peu ce dispositif alors des images
d'autres cours de langue des signes dans
d'autres communes alors bien évidemment
le dispositif a été testé d'ailleurs
comme vous l'avez signalé en fait les
langues les cours de langue des signes
classiques depuis 2009 mais depuis 2009
nous avons inséré dans les cours des
ateliers donc en fait on a un background
à peu près quatre ans avant de pouvoir
nous lancer dans cette année quelques
mots en langue des signes quelques mots
simples peut-être nous ça va quand
bonjour c'est bonjour bonjour voilà donc
pour commencer le journal j'aurais dû
commencer comme ça on va continuer à
évoquer ses cours que vous mettez en
place juste après ce micro-trottoir
connaissez-vous la langue des signes et
puis que savez vous dire là ne parle pas
la langue bicim
jeu sur wii mais bon j'ai pas eu mal
utilité moi je connais personne qui par
la langue des signes du coup bon c'est
vrai que ça m'intéresserait d'apprendre
non j'avais jamais appris d'ailleurs je
n'aime pas ou si et des
plaisirs des organismes zaki qui fait qu
recon apprennent non est ce que vous
aimeriez
maintenant je suis trop vieille je pense
info peur aux jeunes oui mais moi non je
suis trop viennent simplement le minimum
on ne peut pas la prendre c'est trop
c'est trop compliqué
bonjour
au revoir merci
merci c'est comme ça des choses simples
pas du tout j'ai une petite fille
handicapée mais elle parle donc je n'ai
pas eu besoin de l'apprendre donc gêné
par pas ressenti la nécessité de le
faire non mais bon j'avoue j'ai eu un
malade un jour qu'ils étaient mal
entendants je réussis à me faire
comprendre par lui quand même sans signe
avant avec les meilleurs quoi
ces mêmes langues officielles pour
pouvoir à s'exprimer d'ailleurs est ce
que cette langue des signes et
internationale c'est souvent la première
question qu'on nous pose de la réponse
est non la langue des signes n'est pas
international il ya une raison simple
c'est parce que c'est une langue visuel
et donc la façon de vous ressentez les
choses dont vous voyez les choses avec
l'historique n'est pas le même suivant
les arbres à chaque culture à chaque
achat qu un pays donc il faut
réapprendre à chaque fois on entendait
dans le micro trottoir une dame nous
dire qu'elle était trop âgée trop
vieille pour apprendre la langue des
signes en âge mais il n'y a pas d'âge
nous avons d'ailleurs mené des
expériences nous avons mêlé des
adolescents avec des retraités et ça a
très bien fonctionné là vous allez
mettre en place donc des nouveaux cours
de langue des signes de cette rentrée
2014 sur la ville d'elancourt plus
intensive plus rapide aussi pour pour
apprendre dans l'apprentissage de
nouvelles méthodes à qui s'adressent ces
cours quelles sont les personnes qui se
sont déjà inscrites à l'or parmi les
inscrits nous avons bien soudée parents
qui ont des enfants sourds nous avons
des étudiants qui veulent la langue des
signes pour le plaisir nous avons des
gens qui travaillent qui ont des
collègues qui sont sous en face et c'est
vraiment un public un panel très large
et l'intérêt de la langue des signes pu
naître d'une connaissance ou juste
monétaire et paul allen y avoir ensuite
comment vont se passer les cours ce sont
des groupes très restreint
ce sont des groupes de dix douze
personnes maximum les coûts ce sont des
ateliers de trois heures sur deux
samedis samedi matin pour l'instant tu
as tu fait bien motivés bien concentrés
pendant là ça va être bien motivés
concentrés mais justement grâce aux
techniques nous avons aucun moment faire
en sorte dépose à quel moment revenions
sur la grammaire le vocabulaire et à
quel moment justement montrer le sync
qui sera retenue est-ce que c'est
véritablement difficile autant pour une
langue étrangère alors je suis assez
instinctif peut-être moi je dirais que
c'est plus facile qu'il demande
étrangère mais la raison que je donne
souvent est ce que on n'a pas une
nouvelle langue après on a des gestes
associés vous voulez en allant par
exemple votre chien en anglais il faut
apprendre le chien d'aude mais en langue
des signes chien ça reste un chien pour
vous donc dans votre image c'est déjà le
chien il faut juste associe donc dans ce
cas le chien alors vous aurez appris
quelques mots il faut dire bon joueur on
peut dire chien calcite cette édition du
journal il ya un vrai engouement autour
de l'apprentissage est ce que parce que
vous l'avez mis en place en 2000 flas
vous renforcer encore le dispositif ça
veut dire que les gens sont très
demandeurs oui d'ailleurs je dois
remercier les stagiaires qui nous
suivent depuis 2009 parce que on peut
dire en fait que c'est grâce à laurent
du moment que nous sommes allés plus
loin et on leur propose en fait cette
nouvelle formule d'atelier qui dispense
les cours oh les coups sont dispensés
par des professeurs de langue des signes
française qui travaille avec notre
centre de formation depuis
des années où certains plus récemment
nous mixons des professeurs entendant
avec des professeurs sous notamment les
professions souhaitaient afin de vous le
vocabulaire parce qu'il est très
important que l'avocat mieux soit
corrigé des natifs de la langue donc
uniquement par les sons si vous
souhaitez vous inscrire il ya forcément
un petit numéro de téléphone qui va
s'afficher sur votre écran il est encore
possible d'avoir des places il est
encore possible il reste peu de place
mais en fonction en fait du nombre de
personnes intéressées nous réfléchissons
à à mettre une deuxième session ça
pourrait être le cas n'hésitez pas à
vous manifester
on va forcément terminée par la question
du coût est ce que ça coûte cher
l'apprentissage de la langue des signes
alors les tarifs sont simples ils sont
de 15 euros l'heure à titre elle est
individuelle c'est un financement
personnel et 25 euros l'heure s'il
s'agit de financement par l'entreprise
sas à 40 euros pour trente six heures ou
900 euros si l'on sent mon entreprise ça
peut paraître cher il faut savoir que
les cours de l'sf d'un module de 30
heures et coûte en moyenne 250 euros 300
euros pour arriver au niveau auquel nous
allons arriver avec cette méthode
accélérée nous faisons quatre niveaux en
réalité d'un quart et les thèmes sont
moitié moins cher que les offres du
public accueille une petite question
complémentaire vous avez mentionné les
entreprises qui veulent inscrire leurs
salariés justement là aussi les
entreprises sont passées de man 2 pour
apprendre et pour faciliter aussi
l'interaction entre les différents
salariés parce que maintenant on le sait
les quotas dans les entreprises pour
embaucher des personnes en situation de
handicap il faut que ces personnes
puissent s'intégrer il faut que tout le
monde puisse échanger dans le cas où il
est besoin de la langue des signes au
roman qui a de plus en plus
d'entreprises donc en on travaille avec
la mairie d'elancourt donc on a une
personne de la mairie des locaux qui
participera aux cours qui a déjà
commencé d'ailleurs sur une accession
qui a déjà commencé non c'est une
personne debout de télé comme par
exemple bouygues immobilier pardon
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
présenter ce dispositif pour la société
wizard interact c'est avec la ville
d'elancourt ses cours de langue des
signes renforcez intensif dès ce début
d'année 2014 on poursuit cette édition
du 3 janvier avec le conseil général des
yvelines qui a voté son budget primitif
pour cette nouvelle année un milliard
deux cent cinquante six millions d'euros
c'est sont en évolution des dépenses de
fonctionnement limitée à 1% dans le
détail les investissements pour le haut
débit internet se poursuivent pour
conserver l'attractivité du territoire
notamment pour les entreprises et puis
pour les particuliers l'action en faveur
des plus fragiles se caractérise
toujours par l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie
le revenu de solidarité active ou encore
les aides alimentaires en logement au
transport plus ponctuelle le niveau de
recettes est inchangé les français de
plus en plus nombreux à revendre leurs
cadeaux de noël à maurepas un magasin
d'achat et de vente d'occasion voit son
chiffre d'affaires fortement augmenté en
ce début d'année olivier maniscalco est
clair qu'en bien un client vient de me
revendre ce jeu parce que quand il l'a
acheté il s'est trompé de consoles son
neveu à part la console wii il a une
sole ps3 je vais racheter 35 euros et 9
savant 59 secondes
selon un récent sondage opinionway six
français sur dix seraient aujourd'hui
prêts à revendre leurs cadeaux de noël
c'est 10 % de plus que l'an passé les
mentalités évoluent et ce sont les
enseignes spécialisées qui se frotte les
mains dans ce magasin à maurepas on
rachète aux particuliers du matériel
plus ancien mais aussi les cadeaux reçus
au pied du sapin hier 26 décembre était
le le jour des consoles de jeu on a
racheté est quasiment une vingtaine de
consoles de jeux pour des gens qui ont
une nouvelle console qui sont venus nous
revendre leurs anciennes consoles ou qui
nous a vendu la console car il avait
déjà et on a racheté près de 200 jeux
vidéo est fière aujourd'hui la précision
d'un produit est moins importante que
l'utilisation d'un produit ce qui
intéresse les gens c'est d'avoir le jeu
où l'on tout le monde parle s'en servir
allez à la fin puis le revendre pour en
acheter un nouveau aujourd'hui on
consomme le produire ne possède plus et
contrairement aux délais que les sites
spécialisés d'internet peuvent imposer
il si l'achat est immédiat pour ce faire
il suffit d'être majeur est de présenter
une pièce d'identité en salles de ventes
les produits sont ensuite testés par les
techniciens avant qu'acheteurs et
revendeurs tente de trouver un accord
sur le prix le paiement se fait en cash
jusqu'à 750 euros sinon ce sera par
chèque à l'instar des bijoux et des
métaux précieux comme la loi l'exigé
toute l'année je pense que c'est
intéressant de venir ici c'est pas
spécialement les fêtes temps en temps je
viens je revois aussi des trucs voilà
pour débarrasser
envie de changement c'est un bon moyen
d'avoir de l'argent en espèces tout de
suite au lieu de les jeter même si les
chiffres d'affaires restent
confidentielles la période de noël est
clairement une période faste pour les
enseignes spécialisées les articles
rencontrant le plus de succès restent
les produits dits technologiques fin
décembre une centaine de consoles et 300
jeux vidéo ont ainsi été vendus en plus
de 40 téléphone portable et une dizaine
de tablettes numériques
si les cadres trouvent une seconde vie
les sapins aussi et c'est bien sûr
l'essentiel la ville de montigny le
bretonneux se propose de collecter votre
arbre qui a perdu de sa superbe afin de
l'utiliser ensuite pour valoriser les
espaces verts olivier maniscalco nos dix
mois
que faire de son sapin après les fêtes à
montigny le bretonneux les services
techniques de la mairie organise pour la
deuxième année consécutive une collecte
pour vous aider à vous débarrasser de
vos conifères pour ce faire il suffit de
venir déposer son sapin vierges de toute
décoration sac ou support dans l'un des
19 ans clôt répartis à travers la ville
une démarche qui est de plus écologique
puisque les arbres vont être broyés pour
ensuite être recyclé l'idée c'était de
pouvoir valoriser cette matière puisque
avant les sapins été collectées dans le
cadre du ramassage des ordures ménagères
est donc parti à l'incinération donc il
y avait vraiment pas de valorisation de
cette maintient l'idée donc voilà c'est
de pouvoir broyer ses sapins et avec ce
broyat y en a une partie qui aurait
utilisé une situe sur la ville par les
jardiniers les massifs fleuris et sur
les massifs arbustifs et une autre
partie qui part en valorisation sur une
plateforme de compostage l'opération se
tiendra jusqu'au 20 janvier pour
connaître le lieu de collecte de son
sapin rendez vous sur le site de la
mairie à la rubrique cadre de vie
environnement l'an dernier 15 mètres
cubes de conifères avaient été
collectées soit 1247 sapin cette année
la mairie table sur le double d'arbres
déposée par lésigny montain
durant les prochains jours nous
reviendrons sur les événements qui ont
fait 2013 dans le département des
yvelines premier volet de cette
rétrospective avec le premier trimestre
2013 la crise économique est toujours
présente elle frappe même de plein fouet
les 1000 salariés du virgin megastore
l'enseigne de produits culturels déjà
mise à mal depuis plusieurs années par
la concurrence d'internet et ce virage
de la vente en ligne mal négocié
confirme la cessation de paiement dès le
9 janvier 26 magasins dont celui de
montigny le bretonneux fermeront six
mois plus tard après des scènes d'émeute
lors d'une ultime série de soldes
donnant vous verrez on en est capable on
est déterminés on est capable de se
battre comme des lions pour empêcher le
chômage de ravager la vie de millions de
gens pendant que les autres s'en mettre
plein les poches gel des salaires baisse
des effectifs mais maintien des usines
françaises jusqu'en 2016 la corde
compétitivité de renault est signée le
13 mars entre la direction et les trois
principaux syndicats une signature après
de longues semaines de contestation
comme ici dans les yvelines afin au
coeur de l'hiver le mariage pour tous
déchaîne les passions alors qu'ils aient
discuté le projet de loi à l'assemblée
les opposants à l'ouverture du mariage
aux couples de même sexe multiplie les
actions de nombreuses manifestations
sont organisées notamment à versailles
une pétition est aussi relayée à travers
la france au départ du chesnay elle
obtient plus de cinq cent mille
signatures c'est la révolte citoyenne
c'est aujourd'hui le pouvoir va passer
dans la rue et la contestation se
poursuit jusque dans les amphithéâtres
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin invité à débattre le rapporteur
de la loi erwann binet est pris à partie
par des manifestants et doit être évacué
par la police
pendant que cette scène fait le tour des
médias nationaux les étudiants des
compresses loin d'imaginer la non ce qui
sera fait en décembre d'une possible
fermeture de leur université en faillite
ils dansent la folie du harlem shakes
vit ses derniers instants
un autre dossier qui préoccupe le
gouvernement ce début d'année 2013 la
mise en place des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires la réforme doit débuter dès
septembre sur la base du volontariat des
communes et elles sont peu nombreuses à
vouloir se lancer une dizaine dans le
département parmi lesquels poissy ou
trappe pour la majorité des villes il
faudra donc attendre un nom
supplémentaire et le risque de voir ce
sujet déjà peu populaire devenir un
enjeu de la campagne des municipales
les municipales à un an du premier tour
l'ancien ministre chantal jouanno se
rend à magny les hameaux pour soutenir
la candidature de rohr berger elle se
présente face au maire sortant
socialiste et veut marquer les esprits
gérard larcher benoist apparu feront par
la suite le déplacement pour l'épauler
manier une commune au rêve de l'emporter
la présidente de l'ump dans les yvelines
valérie pécresse afin de peser un peu
plus sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines bastion socialiste
dans un département très à droite il
cuisine depuis l'âge de 11 ans on
travaille pour la société lenôtre à
plaisir et tout lui sourit thibault
ruggeri décroche le bocuse d'or grand
prix international de cuisine les
épreuves se déroulaient à lyon c'est son
turbo aux perles d'infusions aux herbes
qui aura fait la différence
une immense joie une immense fierté
sachant qu'il y avait une responsabilité
de représenter la france
vraiment extrêmement contents et
énormément d'émotion
enfin le début de l'année 2013 est aussi
l'occasion de célébrer quelques
anniversaires symboliques le centre
aquatique du lac à montigny le
bretonneux et l'estaminet lieu dédié à
la culture à magny les hameaux fêtent
leurs 10 ans et à versailles la cité
royale célèbre dans le même temps les
400 ans de son célèbre jardinier andré
le nôtre une année complète de
festivités débutent le 12 mars
ce qui a fait l'actualité au cours du
deuxième trimestre de l'année nous
poursuivons cette rétrospective de la
rédaction manifestations politiques et
faits divers au programme
alors que l'année 2013 se poursuit comme
elle avait débuté entre opposition
mariage pour tous ces inquiétudes autour
des rythmes scolaires un autre mouvement
de contestation prend de l'ampleur celui
des bricoleurs du dimanche
ils sont salariés de grandes enseignes
et demandent que leur entreprise puisse
enfin ouvrir légalement 7 jours sur 7 si
demain les dimanches ferme c'est entre
17 et 20% de nos salaires qu'on va
perdre donc
c'est pour ça qu'on se bat aussi 2014
sera sans doute l'année du dénouement
après des semaines de bras de fer le
gouvernement a annoncé son intention de
légiférer
emploie justement ils sont d'avenir ou
deux générations les nouveaux contrats
défendue par françois hollande depuis
les yvelines le 30 avril dernier doivent
permettre d'endiguer un chômage qui ne
cesse de battre des records et les
résultats se font toujours attendre
huit mois plus tard pour l'emploi
annonce une hausse de 8 % des demandeurs
dans les yvelines et pendant que le
président se déplace aux mureaux marine
le pen se rend à versailles elle annonce
que le front national présentera un
nombre historique de candidats aux
prochaines municipales
le département fait partie de ses
priorités alors qu'il n'y avait aucun
représentant bleu marine en 2008 on en
recense cette fois ci à rambouillet
elancourt montigny le bretonneux et
versailles justement
politique et ce retour de pierre bédier
aux affaires l'ancien président du
conseil général des yvelines condamné
pour des faits de corruption a purgé sa
peine les électeurs lui font toujours
confiance il redevient fin juin
conseiller général à mantes la jolie à
l'issue d'une élection partielle qui ne
mobilise pas les foules moins de 30% de
participation
racing et audebert des photos je pense
que ce sera un match très difficile car
on va affronter à la meilleure équipe
est probablement la meilleure de tous
les temps qu'ils veulent ce point il y
avait en revanche beaucoup plus de monde
en ce début du mois d'avril à
saint-germain-en-laye lors du dernier
entraînement du psg avant un choc face à
barcelone en quart de finale de la ligue
des champions un niveau que le club
francilien n'avait pas atteint depuis
lui aussi aura marqué à sa manière cette
année 2013 et plus particulièrement le
second trimestre le trappistes alain
degois fondateur de déclic théâtre il a
révélé arnaud tsamère issa doumbia ou
encore jamel debbouze et à la veille de
son départ à la tête de cette compagnie
qu'il a fondée voici vingt ans il est
promu chevalier de l'ordre des arts et
des lettres on fait bouger des lignes la
de la culture et que peut-être que c'est
tour d'ivoire soit en train de se se se
fissurer et ya une nouvelle culture à
faire je pense que la surrection
culturel est en marche merci madame la
ministre allant de goy qui laisse
également comme témoignage de son
histoire un livre made in trappe où il
s'interroge sur les a priori qui
touchent les jeunes de banlieue depuis
toujours
au cours de ce deuxième trimestre 2013
c'est aussi un autre visage de la
banlieue qui fait la une des journaux
nationaux un très médiatiques faits
divers trouve son dénouement dans les
yvelines à la verrière alexandre jeune
français convertis à un islam radical
depuis quatre ans est arrêté quelques
jours après avoir agressé à l'armé
blanche un militaire à la défense enfin
de ce printemps 2013 on retiendra aussi
l'ouverture tant attendue du ciné 7 à
elancourt le cinéma de quartier entre
enfants dans le 21ème siècle nouvelles
sol nouveaux équipements un an de retard
en raison de nombreux problèmes
techniques lors du chantier
mais enfin des spectateurs ravis depuis
le temps qu'on attendait ça commence à
être lourd - voilà mais je trouve que
c'est très bien
la suite de cette rétro 2013 à découvrir
dès lundi 2013 terminé que vous réserve
2014 vos résolutions à présent c'est au
micro d' elodie mois à nos micros
trottoirs et certainement rentrer chez
moi la martinique parce que je me sens
plus acceptée en france du travail
des jeunes
pour voir en santerre de cette crise du
travail
avoir un bébé la santé que je fasse
plaisir à mon papa pour bien travailler
à l'école d'avoir une vie plus saine
pour pas perdre du poids et
travaille pour parler du travail c'est
une mieux travailler là que l'année
dernière être cool
cool cool lezennes
le journal revient lundi en direct point
complet sur l'actualité locale dès 18h
et nous reviendrons notamment sur la
visite de jean marc ayrault à versailles
c'est en effet lundi que le premier
ministre ait une délégation du
gouvernement se rendront au château afin
de rencontrer une société qui a mis en
place un programme d'amélioration et
d'aménagement des postes de travail pour
les rendre accessibles aux femmes ce
sera à découvrir lundi dans le journal
n'oubliez pas également nourri play
gratuitement sur le site internet de tv
fils on se quitte avec un clin d'oeil
les cigognes sont passés à la maternité
du chesnay rencontre avec le premier
bébé de l'année alain di
luca n'a pas encore deux jours mes amis
lui 44 le 1er janvier 2014 le nouveau né
est toujours mieux dans les bras de sa
maman à l'hôpital du chesnay c'est l'un
des tous premiers bébés de l'année
alors à lui s'est bien terminée ont
approuvé une entente en bonne santé mais
aussi chez unica et les navires en tête
le 1er janvier klich famille et ils
peuvent de fait peser de viau et 150
mais à 37 semaines et quatre jours luca
devait normalement arriver le 25 janvier
sa maman a subi une césarienne le soir
du 31 décembre un réveillon plus que
mémorable on ressent sur une éventuelle
grossesse dès la décennie il y va c'est
principalement le plus important
luca fait partie des cinq bébés venu au
monde le 1er janvier à l'hôpital du
chesnay l'année dernière l'établissement
a accueilli 2210 nouveau né